it's a pleasure to be here today as he
said i'm kathryn williams if i'm not
mistaken this is the last talk of the
day which is appropriate in some ways
because i'm going to tie together a few
themes that we've heard earlier i'm an
ad tech industry as was the quantex
quantcast speaker this morning Peter I'm
going to talk a little bit about pricing
just like our previous speaker and along
the lines of what Ben was just talking
about i'm going to tell you a story so
my story is about bidding strategies for
display advertising how to avoid boiling
the ocean and i was told that this
audience might appreciate or at least
wouldn't mind terribly if I got a little
bit technical so it's going to be a
technical tactical story to end your day
okay so first let me introduce our
protagonist this is epic sis the
protagonist here's our tagline we
provide the technology that empowers
companies to buy and sell online
advertising programmatically so first
and foremost we're a technology company
and we enable and optimize programmatic
buying and selling of online advertising
so we help our technology helps
advertisers to make the most of their
campaigns publishers to make the most of
their inventory and add tech companies
which are built on top of us to make the
most of their data in insights and this
all sits on top of our cloud-based
software platform ok one more standard
marketing slide about our protagonist F
Nexus I think some of these numbers are
a little out of date we are the scaled
independent leader in the space scaled
in the sense that we operate at global
internet scale we have we've grown
year-over-year enormously that's
actually going to be an element of our
story we serve I think our high water
mark was around three billion ads a day
we process an enormous amount of day let
data and we receive an enormous number
of inbound queries per second we're
privately held we've received venture
capital funding from a variety of
partners as well as some firm strategic
partners including Microsoft in WP p
which is the world's largest agency
holding company we have a global
footprint and over a thousand employees
so scaled right now independent might be
more interesting so I just want to point
out briefly the two other the two
juggernauts in our
space the two other internet scale
advertising platforms are Google and
Facebook both of which have B to C like
consumer oriented products and services
as well as their own properties their
own inventory that they monetize get
advertising so we're independent in the
sense that we're agnostic we don't own
any inventory that we monetize and we're
completely anonymous or at least users
are completely anonymous on our system
okay so there's our protagonist now
fortunately our first speaker this
morning talked a little bit about
real-time bidding already so I'm not
going to have to believe are some of
these points but this is the bread and
butter of the app Nexus platform so for
those of you who are not familiar here's
a little diagram when you user little
red faceless user go to a browser and
load up a web page each one of those ad
slots calls out to a platform like
appnexus it may be up Nexus and requests
ads AppNexus then holds an auction or
submits outbid requests actually and for
from different advertisers that are
integrated with our platform requesting
bids for those ad slots we hold an
auction the highest bidder gets to send
their creative in this case I think it's
a hamburger hamburger add back to that
ad slot and this all happens in less
than 100 milliseconds ok so this blew my
mind when I first learned about it about
what three years ago but I think
everyone here is probably more savvy
than I was then so just to be really
crisp about our definition here an ad
impression then is a creative serve to a
single user at a single point in time
via a browser or a mobile app or what
have you so if you hit refresh on your
browser you're going to see a whole new
slew of impressions it's one instance ok
now because there's so many of these
based on people's web surfing habits
even though they transact individually
we price them and think of them in terms
of thousands so you'll hear CPM cost per
meal cost per thousand later on ok now
there are many interesting stories that
I could tell about data science attacks
and there are adventures and dragons and
what have you but today's story I'd like
to focus on some of our core platform
logic so in particular let's start with
a little auction theory okay a second
price or sometimes called Vickrey
auction is a type of sealed bid auction
bitter submit bids without knowing the
bids of the other participants of the
auction an independent third party then
reconciles the bids says who's the
winner the highest bidder wins but
importantly pays the second highest
price in the auction maybe plus 1 cent
now one thing that makes us AB Nexus
runs a second-price auction as do many
other ad exchanges one thing that makes
this so beautiful and so elegant the
reason I mentioning it is because it
lends itself to a very elegant and
natural bidding strategy so here's a
little bit of math for you some game
theory suppose we have n bidders in an
auction say that ice bidder bids VI for
an impression or so rather that's its
value for the impression we're assuming
that each individual bidder has their
own valuation of that object this is
where I'm tying into the car talk that
we just heard about because I am
assuming here that bidders know how to
value those impressions I'll get to that
a little bit more later ok so our bitter
values the impression of V but they bid
be now we say that the auction is
truthful if their bid is equal to their
value makes sense right so their payoff
then while they're going to get no
payoff if they don't win it if they do
win the payoff is the difference between
their bid and the price they pay or
rather their value in the price that
they pay that's their margin so one can
prove that in a second price option
auction rather at least a single second
price auction the bitter optimizes pay
off by bidding truthfully and I'll leave
that as an exercise for the audience
because it is actually very easy to
prove we can talk about it afterwards
but that's very elegant right so now the
problem of bidding in a second price
auction just boils down to how do you
value the impressions in the first place
so here's the valuation problem AppNexus
does this on behalf of clients you
integrate with us directly if they
choose they may have their own
valuations or they can use ours so our
job then is to algorithmically determine
the value of each impression in
real-time on behalf of a buy-side client
now in order to do this they need to
have something that they're measuring so
we I think the phrase direct response
advertising was used earlier we're
usually looking for a click or a
conversion that can be measured be a
pixel or some other sort of event that
you can measure right okay and so the
advertiser usually has some revenue
number associated with that they'll pay
ten dollars for a lead or one dollar for
a click or somebody actually buys
something on an e-commerce website maybe
that's worth a hundred dollars to them
okay so then our job just becomes we
need to measure the expected value of
expected revenue rather of that
impression based on that goal which is
then just the probability of the event
occurring that generates that action or
that revenue times the value of the
revenue times 1000 there's that one
thousand from the CPM units again okay
great so how do we then predict that
probability well there are a large
number again as we heard this morning
there a large number of features that we
could use every one of these ad
impressions has a huge number of
features associated with it and some are
more predictive than others anything
ranging from features of the ad itself
like what is the actual image what is
the size bigger ones can be can have a
higher impact what is the domain or app
that the ad is showing on where's the
geography of the user who's seeing that
now we know that isp geo-locating is not
necessarily good because we're
apparently in Kansas right now but in
general this is a pretty good signal
creative recency and frequency turns out
people get creative fatigue if you see
the same creative over and over again
you're less likely to react to it so
that's when we need to measure how
recently they've seen it and a wide
number of other features as well so you
see them on the list here now the core
appnexus algorithm that's been in place
for a number of years is just the orange
ones so I'm going to focus on
is going forward but there are many many
features and I guess let me just note
also user ID and user segments that's
all the demographic data the Peter was
referring to this morning that can be
used and is highly predictive if you
have it okay so I think this is the
Mathias slide I've got let me just tell
you how do we actually put this data
into practice to make some sort of a
prediction to create a bidding strategy
so this is the app nexus way that it was
it's been done for historically for
several years first of all we cluster
the world of inventory that sea of
inventory into similarly performing
slices so this is going to involve
domain or app and geographical region
among other things these are called
venues these need to be roughly the same
size and big enough to have a see a
large volume of data then an
optimization node is a 3-2 pool or in
particular a buy-side sell-side pair of
campaign creative that's by side by
venue on the other and we're going to
make a prediction / combination like
that so for each one of these by side
sell-side pairs our prediction then is
given by this formula now I don't want
to belabor the actual notation here the
point is that we create a probability
distribution based on what we think the
true event rate of this by side
sell-side combination is going to be for
some given event say it's a conversion
right and we're going to try to estimate
that based on both whatever data we
actually see for that campaign creative
on that venue so that's our capital N
and our little X so it's the actual
observed data as well as some sort of
prior some sort of Beijing prior that
we're going to make based on higher
level historical data say more about
that in a second so when you start out
you have no data right your x is 0 your
end may be there 0 so you're going to
rely very heavily on this prior
probability and then as you gather more
and more data the posterior probability
will shift to the actual and in the long
term it will converge to x over n we
then look for the max likelihood of that
posterior distribution and that's our
prediction ok I promise that's the
Mathias thing in this this deck now what
informs that higher level data well
remember this node that I was just
talking about is a specific campaign a
specific creative against a specific
venue which is a specific slice of
inventories that's very granular so the
higher level data is just coarser
aggregations I'm not going to belabor
like what the exact hierarchy of these
different aggregations is but it can
include data aggregated at the member
level this is like the buyer member
level or the advertiser level or the
publisher level or brand or content
category or even second-order
combinations of these but they're going
to be coarser than the node so basically
we warm start the prediction problem by
calibrating our vision prior based on
the data from the most granular higher
level data sorry most granular higher
levels set that has sufficient data and
then we're good to go okay so to
summarize we now know how to bid in
these online auctions we know how to
start from zero use a asian prior based
on higher level data and then wind up
converging towards an accurate
prediction so an accurate valuation
there for an optimal bidding strategy no
problem right we just go off and apply
this algorithm and bid across the whole
ocean of inventory and we'll be fine ah
here is where our protagonist meets
conflict and we introduce the boiling
the ocean problem also sometimes known
as the peanut buttering problem so what
are these two metaphors have in common
well
as I mentioned at the beginning AppNexus
has grown enormously in the past several
years so when this algorithm was first
designed it used to be that you could
bid on all available inventory and
quickly ramp up get more and more data
and eventually get accurate predictions
but as we brought more and more
inventory onto our platform now the same
campaign is spreading so peanut
buttering it's it's learning impressions
across a huge sea of potential domains
and what have you right and it makes it
harder and harder for it to get those
accurate valuations quickly or you might
say trying to boil the ocean with a
little lighter I've never really been
clear on exactly how that metaphor works
ok so just if you really concrete here
let's just look at some numbers suppose
we have a campaign just to be simple
with two creatives buying on five venues
so that's 10 nodes all right so this is
in the old world suppose that these
venues or rather these nodes have a one
out of two hundred thousand conversion
rate for some conversion that's actually
a realistic and good conversion rate for
some sort of like e-commerce shopping
thing suppose the campaign buys 20
million impressions that average is
about two million impressions per note
and so again on average roughly we have
about 10 conversions pretend that is
pretty good that is enough that we're
going to be able to come up with a
reasonably accurate valuation pretty
quickly if some of those noes are not as
good we'll get 20 pretty fast all as
well but now once the inventory ocean
expands and becomes very very wide we
have say 500 venues of this campaign is
targeting that just meet its targeting
criteria right all of a sudden now we
have 1,000 nodes that same 20 million
impressions that the campaign was
willing to spend to learn or to get
started now gets spread out to 20
thousand impressions per node with on
average point one conversions that is to
say on average most of these nodes have
no conversions whatsoever so we have
nothing so we're still bidding using our
prior higher level distribution and just
wasting money so this is exactly what
happened clients saw
their campaign dollars would go and go
and go into what seemed like a black
hole to them and they wouldn't start
getting the positive results so what
seemed like a good thing having more and
more inventory available to them to be
able to find the users actually became a
very very bad thing all right so here's
the climax of my story our solution a
little bit of foreshadowing because
there's going to be a tow to begin to
water their solution is to focus the
spin out like a bad mystery you probably
saw this coming right you're like you're
probably thinking like I bet I know how
to solve this here's how we solve this
first of all we're going to use that
same higher level data that we talked
about for calibrating our prior before
and now we're going to use it to rank
inventory slices in advance now
previously I was talking about venues
now I'm talking about a system we built
more recently and we've moved away from
venue so I'm just going to say generally
inventory slices but we're going to use
that higher level data whatever
historical they do we have on the
platform to predict the performance on
these inventory slices in advance of a
campaign actually running we're going to
rank them now when a campaign starts
instead of bidding everywhere across all
the possible inventory that passes
targeting we're going to have a bit only
on the top inventory slices depending on
whatever it's targeting it is you know
and then in descending order now stage 4
will quickly test we're not just going
to let it go and go go we'll quickly
test to see whether or not that's going
to be a good inventory size for it and
discard it if not number five will then
move our move down the list so that we
target or allow it to bid on the next
most highly ranked inventory and wash
rinse repeat so this in the steady state
the campaign is achieving one hundred
percent of its daily delivery goals on
what we know is the optimal inventory
because we start at the top of the list
but of course this since this is a
little bit of a multi-armed bandit
problem exploit explorer we're going to
continue to explore the space as well so
broadly then these fall into three main
components these literally map two
components in the back end in our system
the first one is ranking the second one
is toe tip so this is my affectionate
term for it properly speaking it's
called the quick test but I still
for toe tip and then the third component
that glues it all together is the
control system so as the day new ma of
my story I guess I'd like to tell you a
little bit more about the ranking system
and the toe tip system which is my
favorite part and then see what if you
have any questions so the ranking I
didn't include technical details here
but the basic idea is that we're going
to employ standard machine learning
techniques and that higher level data
that I've been referring to to predict
the probability per inventory slice now
here we also call them sell side keys so
my terminology is getting peanut
buttered we use predicted these
probabilities then to rank the slices so
here on the right you see a potential
list of cell side keys or inventory
slices right now because remember there
are a whole bunch of different features
we could have used as our higher level
or course aggregations we carried out
some feature selection this was actually
a pretty interesting process so we use
logistic regression with l1
regularization to choose which features
would be most predictive right of these
higher level ones and it turned out it
was pretty interesting app and domain
very predictive brand country group
combinations apparently some brands work
very well in certain country groups or
that was that combination is meaningful
and brand category content category
combinations wound up being very
predictive of how well a campaign would
do so with those three features selected
then now each one of those is actually a
categorical variable and they have very
very high category hi cardinalities so
apps and domains in particular have like
tens of thousands of values on our
system if not even hundreds of thousands
so we have to be a little bit careful
here so what we do then is take these
categorical variables and then translate
them into the actual event rates that we
see on those individual categories and
plug the numerical value into our
regression so at the end of the day we
have a standard logistic regression on
these three features that we use to make
our prediction what's lovely about this
is that when we were doing the valuation
problem and creating that prior
distribution we knew it wasn't accurate
and matter
because when you're pricing accuracy
matters a lot but here it's just the
relative probabilities that matter we're
just ranking and so the in accuracy not
such a big deal because the relative
ranking comes through okay enough about
that I will say we use coordinate
descent in the actual implementation but
okay and so then finally the toe tip my
favorite part partly because I was there
when it was born the basic idea here is
that we're going to metaphorically dip
our toe into the water of each inventory
slice see whether it's good if it's not
good pull our toe back out if it is good
dive in so less metaphorically for each
campaign we're going to start bidding if
we receive an event on that inventory
slice for that campaign great dive in
keep going it's done this past however
if we keep bidding and bidding and
bidding and it doesn't receive an event
and the probability that that node that
is that campaign inventory size
combination is good drops below lambda
where lambda is some threshold value
then we're going to stop bidding so
we're going to bid until the probability
that it's good drops below lambda now
again we're going to use a page and
prior here here it's going to be an
uninformed prior but the point is lambda
now is the tolerance for mistakenly
rejecting good slices so if lambda is
very high we're going to be very
aggressive it's going to be a very quick
toe tip if lambda is low we're going to
bid for a long time before we decide
that we're just not going to get an
event we're going to throw it out so we
can control that and it's
straightforward to compute what the
maximum n is for a given lambda I mean
it's just some calculus our goodness
criterion for a node is typically a
minimum conversion threshold so for the
ranges that we usually see on our
platform we wind up with end in the low
tens of thousands range so this is great
right we can quickly within like tens of
thousands of impressions decide whether
or not a given inventory slice is worth
spending on and if it's not just toss it
out and
move down our list of potential keys so
here then let me just sort of
graphically show you the control system
at work let's suppose here on the right
that the oops we've put the first four
keys in to bid the first to pass the
third one failed the fourth one passed
so the one two and four on that list
keep bidding we add two more from our
control system because we don't have
quite enough delivery one passes one
fails we add two more etc until we've
gone through the whole ranked list and
we have sufficient delivery and it's all
the best inventory for this campaign so
in the end you see the protagonist wins
because he/she it figures out how to
boil just enough water for tea and not
spread the peanut butter too thin thank
you